I had a hilarious situation so I the
whole point of this was that I went to a
wedding in Italy and one of the things
there were all sorts of Italians and
Americans because it was a joint
italian-american Jewish wedding
interestingly in northern Italy very
interesting ceremony and one of the
things that was revealed was that the
wedding being slightly outside of the
city we would be taken to via a bus and
of course the bus had 42 seats and there
were 52 people that needed to go on the
bus and several others that came along
so on the way to the wedding there were
more than a dozen people who had to you
know calls had to be made locals had to
bring their cars and start giving people
rides I made it onto the bus but once we
arrived at the venue we were told the
bus doesn't leave to go back to the city
in everybody's hotels until 2:30 in the
morning and it's a one-hour ride and of
course a lot of Americans being less
into the all-night wedding compared to
Italians myself included started
thinking about how would we get back
earlier if we want to get back earlier
there's no uber there what are we gonna
do
so around midnight or 12:30 I think it
was the wedding started at 4:00 p.m.
around 12:30 myself and my girlfriend
and another couple we said let's get
ourselves a taxi and we talked to
someone at the venue they said no
problem
we've got a taxi it's a fixed price back
to the city they'll be here in 20
minutes they show up we ride back and as
we start riding back I noticed that The
Meters running and it's already well
beyond 50% of what the fixed price was
supposed to be so I'm thinking well if
it costs way more than half to get out
to pick us up because it was like late
night out of the city so they run the
meter both ways it's going to be way
more than the price I was quoted when we
get back so my Italian not being nearly
as good as my French I just kind of
start Italian izing Spanish words so I
attempted to ask the guy whether it's a
fixed price which in Spanish it's bad
SEO FIFA right fixed price so I say to
the guy something like it but it's your
fee huh right I mean I don't that's it's
not even really Italian and the guy and
I later found out that that je sound is
not even a sound in Italian like fijo
can't can't
be a word in Italian because that sound
doesn't exist and the guy looked at me
and he said fijo a kiss Enzo meaning
hee-haw in what sense which of course
he's not saying that's not a word buddy
and I just started signaling with my
hands to try to sort of say like you
know fixed-fixed in some way and then he
says ah FISA and I say yes yes yes
that's what I mean and we figured out
that it was indeed a fixed-price but he
just has to run the meter anyway as a
result of that so my Spanish Italian was
a sight to be seen
for sure yeah that all sounds really
cool I mean can you generally just do
that you just take Spanish and slightly
pronounce the word a little bit
differently and then boom you have
Italian because hey if you're trying to
learn two languages at one time see an
Italian may be the way to go it's very
similar and if people speak slowly the
most common thing I was saying was
slowly and again please and then I would
basically understand 85% of what they
were saying but I just don't know the
words like I actually studied French so
I'm much more able to actually speak in
French than I am Italian even though I
can understand much more Italian because
it's just so similar to Spanish